hey everybody and welcome to a brain
video today I have another 5 mid-tier
money making methods for you guys I find
once you get to a mid-level account the
amount of methods you have for making
money and getting experience really
starts to grow this one I personally
have a lot more fun trying out different
methods so all of these methods today
are going to require between the levels
of 50 and 70 for the most part some will
be a little higher and some will be a
little lower but just generally around
that tier and if guys hope you enjoy and
let's get started alright starting off
and number 5 is killing the crazy
archaeologist for those who don't know
the crazy archaeologist resides in the
wilderness around level 20 I believe
he's not a super high tier boss but he
can be killed with 50 magic with eibon's
blast if you want however 75 for the
Trident would be ideal but anything in
between will work the estimated profit
per hour was only gonna be between 300
and 400 K however I really find it fun
to kill his boss he's quite a few
average drops however he does drop the
odium shard - which is worth 770 K and
the malediction ward which is worth 230
KS who does have a couple valuable drops
and they are not extremely rare you have
a buy the one in 128 chance of getting a
shard and a 1 in 256 chance of giving a
specific one he also has an uncommon
drop of onyx bolt tips which is worth
about 100 K so for Garry definitely I
bring a trident and I'm bringing the
frames and rims bottom for the three
items I'm gonna keep I'm also just
bringing some other very inexpensive
magic year like the saradomin cape blue
wizard had mystic boots and some room
gloves so my risk right now is that
under 100k it's really not too much for
my inventory I'm just bringing prayer
potions you need to pray a range and
some food so the easiest way to get here
by far is using the burning amulet you
want to go to the Bandcamp teleport it
which is in level 17 wilderness so it's
actually relatively close from here just
gonna run a little bit north west until
you get to the runes so as soon as you
get through you're gonna want pretty
range and start just attacking him with
the Trident now you protect from all
this range damage and as long as you
don't get in melee range he can't
actually damage you except for these
books which he can Chucky you but
they're very easy to dodge so it's not
that big an issue so he's right in the
middle here and you kind of want to get
to a more open area because if you get
kind of stuck in between stuff it's a
lot harder to dodge his books which I'll
show you in a second and you don't want
to get with a melee range either so we
only have 225
which is not a whole lot and the Trident
really rips room quickly
so three knowledge is what you have to
dodge I kind of like there but it has a
one volley of three books and then the
following volley of two so you have to
be aware of that but really you
shouldn't be taking that much damage as
this is probably a little excessive for
monkfish however there is minor chance
that a PK or may come and try to kill
you now if you're playing that off-peak
hours ortho I'd be a little more risky
you can go into world eighteen the
bounty hunter world and there's actually
one in five chance of it dropping a
mysterious emblem which is actually
worth 100k which then makes this
actually very profitable however you
have to compete with other peak heirs
and other people they're trying to mess
you up so the first drop is 25k of
cannonballs that's pretty nice it's not
the best money in the game by any means
but it's fine there are some items that
you can get fairly commonly because you
can get probably 30 kills an hour here
and the drop is only one that at 128 so
it's relatively quick coming in at
number four is killing Kerr asks whether
on task or off task they're both
relatively good now this does come with
a fairly hefty requirement of 70 slayer
so it's one of the higher requirements
of this video however it is a nice afk
method to get between 400 and 600 K an
hour depending on your luck your gear
and the current prices of the items to
get here it is in the Arella cos slayer
dungeon so you really do have to do
quite a bit of running now the quickest
teleport is a slayer ring to the
entrance and then you can either go
through the agility shortcuts or run
through the whole thing as far as gear
really all you need is a rune cross but
with broad bolts broad bolts are very
important if you're gonna be ranging
them
now you can melee them and you will get
the bit quicker kills I believe however
really like how afk the range setup is
you don't have to bring any food this is
one of the few monsters wear a ring
wealth is actually valuable because they
do have coin drops fairly frequently and
if you're really lazy no one pick them
up you can be worth a few just to have
you bring it wealth now the caresse has
a bunch of things in the drop table and
I seen two valuable however has 10k coin
drops limper roots this white berry drop
it just guys worth 10k tons of herbs
seeds in the very rare chance of getting
the leaf fleeted battle axe however
that's still not worth that much only
100k but it drops of runes and just a
lot of mildly valuable stuff to adds up
quite quickly for an inventory setup you
really want to bring some random potions
and some alchemy ruins because they do
drop pretty frequently alcohol stuff and
if you plan on staying here a while
want some way of getting rid of it so
out grooms are very nice and the last
thing I like about this method is the
fact you actually get moderately okay
range experience not a ton but you can
get between 30 and 50 K range experience
really depends on how much you're paying
attention but it's something and
actually quite a bit better than most
money making methods coming in at number
three is a buying from the food shop in
the Warriors guild now the only real
requirement is to be able to get into
the Warriors guild so what you will need
to get in here is a combination of a
hundred and thirty between attack and
strength or alternatively you can have
ninety nine and one the most effective
way to get this is just to have
sixty-five attack in sixty five strength
or something around that you also need
that between fifty nine hundred K not a
lot of cash but what you're gonna be
buying is items from Lydia now he
actually sells potato with cheeses and
plane pieces at a very discounted price
compared to the gran exchange the plain
pizza itself or 382 and the potato with
cheese itself for 350 for now the profit
per hour varies a lot here depending on
the prices right now you'll probably be
getting between 400 and 500 K an hour
I've gotten up to seven or eight K
before and as low as 300 K so it's kind
of a range of profits per hour but this
is a really good method for if you get
wiped clean Dori just tell you the money
for some reason to do this for an hour
you really don't need much more than a
couple hundred K and it's really nice
method to get your bankroll starting so
basically just have to hop world look
and see if somes in stock and now you're
gonna be fighting with iron men quite a
bit as well as bots so you don't want to
do this all the time you mean it during
off-peak hours is very beneficial
because there'll be less people doing
this all right we found couple plain
pieces and potato with cheese in this
world but adds up really quickly if the
worlds are relatively empty and not a
lot of people doing it if it's busy it
might consider coming back later that
communion number two is killing revenant
now this has been one of my favorite
methods to make money for the last two
months pretty much since its come out
now obviously this is a pretty high risk
method because it's in the wilderness
and it's a PvP hotspot
however the profit per hour can be
extremely good but it varies quite a bit
I would say your guarantee at least 400
to 500 K an hour if you don't die you
get upwards of a millionnaire or two
million hour if you get lucky however on
the flip side if you die you kid go
negative or just break even another
thing I like about these guys is that
you can kill them with a lot at
different
you're the most ideal is a blowpipe in
just some basic rain gear can be a level
50 and just kill the revenue amp in the
revenant pyro fiend or he can be a level
100 126 and just killed a remnant dragon
you have a lot of freedom and what you
can do there the one item you will need
is the bracelet of aetherium otherwise
you're gonna take italian damage from
the revenant so what I bring is a
blowpipe black tea I'd body black tea i
chaps snakeskin boots archer helm or a
DIY 50 wanted Ava's accumulator in Yemen
of glories I'm currently risking just
over 100k now for my inventory bring a
prayer potion or super restore a ranging
potion and a stamina potion now the ear
I use a burning amulet to laugh amazed
it's the most direct and low requirement
message to teleport from here you're
gonna run a little bit to the east and
go down into the revenant hole now most
of the revenant cave is above level 30
wilderness so to get away from a peak
area really just gonna have to run them
however there was a small section at the
bottom that is actually below level 30
wilderness so if you react quickly
enough that you can teleport out before
he get tele blocked now I find for my
level the best monsters to kill are the
remnant imp has revenant pyro fiend
let's see your revenant demons nice the
revenant hellhounds a nice easy one and
I usually will pray eagle-eye because
the revenant
heal a lot which is quite annoying you
really need the ride eps to get them
down before they start spamming their
heal over and over and over again so you
can see right now I'm actually in level
30 wilderness so I could teleport away
if I noticed be care quickly enough and
really if you're paying close attention
you really should not die that
frequently so you can see I just got
five battle stabs just a nice common
drop worth about 40 3k so I personally
like being worlds with not a ton of
people but some people you'll want to be
alone because then of a peak higher hops
on to that world
you are gonna be the first one to get
attacked however you don't want to be
too crowded or else you're not gonna be
able to kill revenant coming in at
number one is smithing steel bars in the
blast furnace now you can do this at a
very low level all you need is level 30
smithing however I would recommend at
least 60 the reason for that is you
don't have to pay these little chumps
over here to operate the blast furnace
for you now so it saves you a little bit
of money now stuff you will need for
smithing steel bars is a coal bag
absolutely you need the 100% you'll want
weight-reducing equipment
that's not required and ice gloves if
you have them because they're very handy
and it saves you an inventory spot so
the start off here you're gonna want to
put some money in the coffer because
these guys need some money just like the
rest of us if you just put in 100k that
should be good for about an hour now
I've already done this but what you need
to start by doing is put an inventory of
coal into the furnace before you begin
the press of the process if you put your
iron in first it's gonna make iron bars
even and so it's gonna keep messing up
so we're gonna let do is come over here
with 27 coal check them on the conveyor
belt hasn't run back and grab both iron
and coal so now we put an inventory and
imagine and then we're gonna run back
here so you want to fill your coal bag
with coal and then withdraw a full
inventory of iron it's not only if he
was just run over here to the conveyor
belt click on it once it'll empty the
entire thing of iron for you you're
gonna wanna hit 1 on your keyboard to
make it quicker right click empty your
coal bag and then we'll click on the
conveyor belt again and hit yes now you
can run down here in the ice gloves
while I'm actually cool the bars for you
you'll hit on the all button just below
the steel bar section run back to the
bank and repeat the process we'll do one
more time so deposit the steel bars
withdraw the coal use your coal bag on
steel bars withdraw more iron run back
to the conveyor belt click on put or on
the conveyor belt hit the one button
empty your coal bag click on it again
hit the one button run down here pull
down the bars pick up your bars run back
and Bank him it's a really easy process
you'll get the hang of it quickly and on
top of that you'll also get 60 to 70
case mitting experience an hour which is
actually a very nice way to level up
your smithing and at the current prices
you can expect to get between 600 K and
800 K an hour although that can go up
and down quite frequently anyway guys
that is about it I hope you enjoyed the
video if you did don't forget to leave a
like and I will see you the next one